welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul AKA The Fly kid who isn't
Caleb's daughter and this video we're
breaking down Westworld season 4 episode
3. it's filled with major reveals a ton
of Easter eggs and lots of things that
call back at the first season however we
start off with Bernard who we last left
entering the sublime at the end of the
third season we begin with him waking up
a motif that starts off several
character rocks in the show we find him
in Arnold's house a place that season 2
ended at and it was also where Dolores
ran most of her operations from early on
in season three he's holding the maze in
his hand which is snatched by his son
Charlie who is Alive and Well in this
simulation you can instantly tell this
isn't the real world due to the aspect
ratio going 16x9 which is something
that's always used in a simulation
Bernard follows him out into a green
field which is something that we've seen
in the sublime at several points this is
also where Sorak took Maeve at the start
of season 3 episode 6 and there's other
things that call back to the series here
we can catch a tree up on a hill and
this looks similar to the one that
Dolores spent her looping at painting
it's also where she died at the end of
season 3 and running away from it is a
white horse a white horse has been used
in the earlier credit sequence but its
meaning goes far beyond that white
horses are symbolic on a number of
levels and they can either mean death or
triumph over adversity Clementine rode
one at the end of season 2 when she was
carrying a killer virus that made the
hosts all turn on each other archet also
saw one running through the graveyard
before it hit the town after stumbling
on the massacre there in season 2
episode 8. the tree itself also ends up
burning further bringing a Biblical
imagery and aketchita also returns this
idea of a tree also reflects Bernard who
sees several timeline branches some of
which can lead to destruction whether he
has to take a couple more trips down
memory lane first and he sees not only
the saloon from Westworld but also the
massacre carried out by Teddy and delore
well it's complicated now the wolf is
also there and this had a number of
meanings such as its tied to Native
American cultures and the fact that
wolves made for life and hunting packs
this shooting was later reflected in the
Westworld massacre at the end of the
first season which gets its own nod come
the end of the episode Bernard then
steps in the streets from the end of
season 3 and we can see the word inside
there which was the name of the company
that Sorak owned Bernard also spots the
tower an important thing that's popped
up in these first three episodes and he
walks along a pathway surrounded by
water similar to the entrance to delos
this likely hints at the tower being
owned by hail and he's running it from
the company inside he has a sit down
that reminded me a lot of the Matrix and
we learned that the other hosts are
often paradises of their own choosing
with this being a program they can
select what's best for them but Bernard
has chosen to remain in the past hitting
that he still has ties to the real world
so at this point that he's given a gift
and we discover that one year in the
real world is a thousand in the sublime
it's been talked about quite a lot how
time moves slower in the simulation and
this was seen in episode 2 from season 3
when Maeve monitored Insight synth bombs
the level up from where she was the
hosts inside the sublime have spent this
time mapping out every single choice and
outcome which they then give to Bernard
he is now the only person that can save
the world as he's seen all the pathways
and knows all the outcomes he's very
much become a host version of rehoboam
who using a complex algorithm could
predict and adjust its plans to plot a
course for the future in which humanity
is saved it's a complicated concept and
the simplest way I can think to explain
it centers pretty much around the video
game level for example if you've played
a level time and time again then you
know where all the enemies are and how
to navigate it however you won't play it
exactly the same every single time
because it's impossible to do that due
to minor variables some enemies May pop
up when you're in a slightly different
position to how you approached it last
time and you yourself might even try
something different the level is still
exactly the same though so you adjust
your route due to the knowledge you have
in order to get the same outcome and
complete it I hope that makes sense
probably doesn't but Bernard basically
has the positions of every possible
outcome he just needs to adjust things
in order to stay on a certain pathway
unfortunately for him every scenario
leads to his death and though he could
stay in the sublime he decides to return
home now we're taking a big L here as we
thought him waking up was yes in the
future but it's probably only been the
eight that's been brought up time and
time again however this could still be
far in the future though we don't quite
get it confirmed now I've admitted I'm
wrong yet and I want you to admit you
find these breakdowns to be okay so as a
thank you yeah just hit the thumbs up
button and make sure you subscribe you
damn son of a [ __ ] give me a rent
anyway he starts taking stubs Through
the Motions he's been stubborn hey and
stayed there guarding over him in season
3 Bernard rewrote his programming after
finding him in the park and he's looked
out for him ever since then Bernard now
wants to test some things to see which
specific timeline they're on as there's
so many slight variations that it would
be difficult to decide after just waking
up even though he does have some idea I
brought you a souvenir oh snow globe
from Sublime
good
I've eliminated half the possibilities
now after the credits we see Maven Caleb
arriving in Temperance this Mafia asked
trip to the 20s is set in a recreation
of Chicago which was home to the
gangsters at the time like Al Capone the
episode itself is titled Annie's Valles
which is the name of the decade in
French noted for its artistic
achievements and cultural significance
we see it still as dirty as Ryan Aries
mum when she finds out he's watching
Thor and she's got the house free for
the night
foreign
[Applause]
no expense on their prisons this is
likely United Jurassic Park in which Jon
Hammond also said the same thing the
voice you're now hearing and John have
sped no extent we spared no expense
spectacular disaster noise
spectacular disaster they have no
expense in case you don't know Michael
Crichton was an author that wrote both
the book Westworld and Jurassic Park
showing that it's all connected now the
entrance to the park is a beat for beat
Recreation of how it played out in the
first and second episode there's so much
attention to detail here and Caleb
shoulder badges someone which both Teddy
and William did in episodes one and two
respectively there's also people
searching for a bootlegger and in the
original Park this was the sheriff's
department searching for Hector when we
get a close-up of the poster we can also
see that his name is Hector and he later
carries out the saloon robbery similar
to how the original did his gang is
exactly the same too and they arrive
much like how they did in episode 4.
they shoot one of the authorities upon
pulling up and in the gang is a copy of
armistice who you'll likely recognize
because of his snake tattoo there are of
course archetypes that most of the parks
are built around and we saw similar
Dynamics when we went to Shogun World in
season two there's also a can that
rolled towards Caleb's butt which in
Westworld of course initiated the
Dolores side quest we can see that
there's a copy of her as well and she
later leads the Westworld Massacre
mission that Maven Caleb find on the
fake level
supposed to be better than Pariah now
this brothel in Pariah Easter actually
talks about appeared in the first season
as a secret place but I I can't show you
that can't show you get it off
now they head to the saloon which is the
exact same layout as how the original
one was and we hear a remix of bad guy
by Billy eilish playing out on the piano
this is called the butterfly Tavern and
the one in Westworld was named the
Mariposa which also means butterfly in
the season 3 Park that we visited it was
called the Taverna Del far Valley which
too means butterfly in Italian did I get
uh pronounce that right now it's really
either way it's really good work by the
creative team and out with Bernard and
stubs they arrive at the roads and Diner
this is a very forebuilding name that
means where something can no longer
survive or thrive in its current
situation this is very symbolic for the
pair who now have to team up with a new
character in order to progress she is
being hunted likely by Helen William who
send hosts out to meet her that Bernard
comes across in the parking lot to the
sound of Call on Me by Blondie Bernard
ends up kicking the crap out of them
this time he's doing it by himself due
to knowing their moves ahead of time
whereas in the past he had to resort to
letting his evil programming come about
to take them down got lots of flashes of
the scene from Terminator 2 here and
across the country we catch Frankie
using a CB radio to contact her father
it shows how much Caleb is trying to
live under the radar as this old Tech
would likely completely be out of
commission due to the decade we're in
Spider-Man calling Frankie tell Carver
he's His Own Worst Enemy and the mother
and daughter end up having to leave
because he's duplicated the first clue
for this comes outside when Frankie asks
him
we'll move
the one that you taught bear bear
but I'll show you when we get to the
safe house he has no idea what she's
talking about or he just doesn't
remember it like Boris Johnson
now we've been over Fidelity a lot in
these breakdowns and I did say last week
that I thought the senator and his wife
will likely complete copies what about
this kind of debunks all that due to him
not remembering I'm kinda in two minds
about it like helloris as William did
say in episode 1 that he remembered
going to the Hoover Dam as a kid so I do
think that he might have passed the
Fidelity test and if we look at the
episode names for the series The Sixth
episode does have that as a title
possibly handing out where we're going
but yeah this at least shuts down the
idea that they all have it now outside
we also see the Banksy parody from the
first episode and also a new bit of
graffiti that says free free will
Humanity of course didn't have it
because rehoboam decided the path that
everyone would walk on and it held
people back from getting certain jobs so
that they could never progress this
machine was just trying to do what was
best for Humanity by guiding everyone in
the path that was most likely to avoid
destruction Sorak in it were of course
painted out as the villains so it is
interesting that Bernard is seen as the
hero even though he's basically doing
the same thing Frankie also has a Teddy
which is a nod to Teddy now at this
point we meet a member of the cause who
resides in The Condemned lands she rocks
up in a Buggy car that looks like the
commercial version of the ones delos
used to ride around in in the second
season we learn a little about them
outside the fact that they've been
hiding there looking for something might
even certainly him there were decades in
the future as we know from episode 1
that William was buying up a lot of
wastelands the new park was built on
this and if it fell again then they
could probably settle out there there's
also the yellow spell there that they
hover over the top you know when you
they go to Mexico movies and they put
this yellow filter over the top of
everything well they've got that here
and that wasn't there when they were in
the area in season three when they
reached their location they arrive on
quads and we see that they're led by
Daniel who you might recognize from into
the Badlands little is known about them
but this area could be out in Nevada
near where William was trying to buy up
Bernard has come to warn them that
they're in danger and he promises to
give them what they're looking for out
in the desert he says there's a weapon
potentially linking back to his
Discovery in season two though it could
be a number of things at this point now
back at the butterfly we hear some
classic Westworld music playing on the
piano that was also in the original Park
the Maeve copy also uses her dialogue it
said this here's the new world
and in this world you can be whoever the
[ __ ] you want this is the new world
and in this world
you can be whoever the [ __ ] that you
want
my delivery was far better at this point
we get the first fly in the episode at
which we learn a lot more about later on
is copies of Clementine and it all
builds the Hector's approach who rides
into the sounds of Enter Sandman by
Metallica there's also the chain that's
tied to the safe but here it's pulled by
a car Hector slides up with Maeve by the
bar reflecting their interaction in
Westworld but this is could chill by the
real Maeve killing them both it's a
great scene in which you may have been
Caleb ride with the dead to sneak into
the admin areas of the park the blood on
Frankie's bear makes her follow a trail
to Carver and we get a halloween-esque
scene where she and her mother hide in
the house as he searches for them the
pair make it out but they do a bait and
switch and end up making it seem like
Frankie has been taken to the park at
the park itself Maven Caleb are dumped
down and we see the technicians wearing
the same overalls that the staff did in
Westworld there's several elements of
this level that mirror the park
including hosts having Concho that and
also some admins on iPads upon grabbing
one Maeve realizes it's all fake and we
then see the response team carrying the
Famas like guns that the security team
also had in the park the woman who
mentioned the secret game before arrives
and she's brought a crew with her you
also get the arrival of a Dolores Teddy
and a version of Angela to the right of
them maybe should at this point and she
of course would still get damaged
because she's technically a host Caleb
shoots the Dolores duplicate potentially
foreshadowing how he might end up having
to do this later on Christina is also
notably absent in this entry but there
are some major ties to things we heard
last week which we'll talk about in just
a bit now behind the scenes we encounter
the creepy looking drone hosts that
first appeared in Journey Into Night
looking like Lord Zed from the Power
Rangers these hosts were off Network
ones that were assigned to carry out
super secret tasks that were unfit for
most of the staff's eyes we see one
carrying a tray of maggots which of
course eventually grow into flies great
great trivia at the channel now we then
sees something be manipulated on a
cellular level which is referred to you
as a parasite that could potentially
alter human behavior there exists some
in nature that actually make the animal
they're in and their own life so that
they can go to the animal that eats the
one they've just killed we also see the
black goo being worked on by the drones
and this is what we saw pouring out of
Anastasia's gunshot wound last week
turns out that the Flies are being
infected with this black goo and they're
likely used in the same way that
pollination does to carry this parasite
into the human now they clearly also
hunt after humans and we see how they're
attracted to Caleb standing behind the
glass it's at this point that the tower
sounds off which may can hear about
Caleb can't those in fact it can also
pick up on it too or it may be the
parasite which then directs its Host
this idea of being unable to hear
something was brought up last week by
the homeless man that Christina came
across
[Music]
hear it
Tower it's coming from the tower no one
could hear his music but me
the birds he talked about how only he
could hear the frequency along with the
birds this is very important as in the
next scene Christina came across several
dead ones on the ground who had likely
end in their own lives similar to the
people being experimented on here these
birds were likely guinea pigs for the
frequency and outside of the homeless
man no one can hear the tower amongst
the people we can see Jim Navarro who
was infected last week he's played by
Josh Randall who's part of the Navarro
cartel in Ozark which was pointed out by
Michael Nares on our last video it can
get them to do simple tasks but it can
also make them shoot themselves so not
something that you really want super
messed up and Frankie is wheeled out to
draw Caleb in it's a trap and it turns
out that she's a host her face opens up
much like the child version of Ford and
this sprays forth several of the Flies
which crawl into Caleb now this is
obviously something that could be a
death sentence for him and judging by
fake Frankie's dialogue Hale wanted him
there and very interested to find out
why he was as he was on the side of the
hosts when we look at season three not
only did he help out Dolores but he also
sided with Maeve and helped to destroy
rehoboam now with hail being a copy of
Dolores it means that she shares all of
her early memories in season 3 we saw
that when Caleb trained with the army
that they used hosts for hostage
practice and at the end of the mission
that the Army basically let the soldiers
do what they wanted with the women Caleb
took down several of them from
assaulting Dolores which hail would
likely remember too gonna be interesting
to see if this buys him favor and what
hell actually wants him for on the
outside of the cell Maeve ends up
kicking the crap out of William who
murdered her and her daughter in one of
his most sadistic visits whether he
returns and may realizes he's a host
which leads to the pair both being
captured anyway that ends the episode
lots of really nice call backs and no it
didn't Advance the plot all that much
I'm still enjoying the journey we're on
and of course love to hear your thoughts
so make sure you comment below and let
me know we're in a competition right now
giving away three copies of everything
everywhere all at once on the 15th of
July and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode repeat the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now save that to you
then message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out our
breakdown of the boys which will be
linked on screen right now the last
episode in the season such a good
episode so definitely head over there if
you've got any questions or you just
want to see the Easter eggs by the way
thanks for singing through the video
I'll be poor and I'll see you next time
take care peace